talk about marginal determinism as a
another property that allows suddenly
things to become
tra great thank you ke for the
introduction um so yeah I'll be talking
about marginal determinism in structured
decomposable circuits uh that's a lot of
words but it will hopefully become much
clearer what this means uh in just a few
minutes
um okay so let's start by looking at um
you know prob logical queries so there
are a few particular types of queries
which I want to focus on uh which are
relevant for for this marginal
determinism property now the first one
we've already seen um a few times uh in
the workshop this week so this is
marginal map so the idea is that you
have uh here a distribution over
variable over sets of variables q andh
and then uh what you want to do is to
um what you want to do is to maximize
um uh find the most likely instantiation
of Q uh when you've marginalized out the
other variables H um another example
which kind of fits into this um uh the
same sort of thing um which we've also
seen is uh trying to do uh some
operations in factorized databases so we
saw a bit in arm talk um that there are
special conditions that you need in
order to be able to do
do projection on factorized databases
and actually it turns out that these two
problems um share share a very close
relationship so here you have basically
the join of of some some some relations
and then you project onto this cell of
abls Q or sell of attributes q and then
you try to do do a count essentially um
and there are a number of other queries
like marginal conditional entropy uh for
distributions causal inference which I
will talk about more uh later in the
talk um which also happen to require
exactly this this this marginal
determinism property um so yeah
hopefully at least one of these um is of
interest to you so um let's continue um
so okay so how how have people looked at
how to do this right how to actually uh
be able to compute these these queries
so um I'm going to focus on exact
computation so I'm just going to look at
cases where uh we can say oh you know
given a circuit or given some
representation we can uh find some way
of of computing this marginal map
exactly in one go um so um yeah Yen
presented a very nice uh algorithm for
essentially uh sort of iteratively
improving uh the the estimate of the of
the map uh until eventually it can
converge exact ly but I'm just looking
at essentially here circuits where where
you can uh just do this marginal map in
in one pass um so there are a few sort
of formalisms which have been developed
for saying when you can do this uh one
of these uh is so-called Q valid pseudo
trees um so pseudo trees we saw uh from
from reena's talk uh when she was uh
presenting Andor graphs and essentially
what a q valid pseudo tree is is
basically a pseudo tree where uh the
variables in Q appear at the top of the
pseudo tree so here for example if if Q
was ABCD then then this would be a q
valid a q valid pseudo tree and this
allows you to to you know once you turn
this into a nandal graph it allows you
to do um uh marinal map in a single
pass
um there are also these um um path
constrained F trees in factorized
databases so um this has a has a very
similar principle um so essentially if
you want to project onto a set of
variables uh that means marginalize out
the other variables um then you have
exactly the same type of condition uh
with these uh F trees essentially the
the variables which you keep the the um
the Q variables have to sort of appear
at the at the top of the at the top of
the tree um let's look at another
example um so we have uh elimination
orders and so-called constrained
elimination orders so um elimination
orders are a way of you know doing
inference in graphical models
essentially um or or way of specifying
how you do inference in in graphical
models um and so usually you would want
to choose the elimination order which
gives you uh the sort of fastest
inference or equivalently the smallest
circuit um but if you want to be able to
compute uh marginal map with respect to
Q for example then you need these Q
constrained elimination orderings and
what this means is basically the Q
variables have to appear at the end of
the ordering
um and we also have these Q constrained
Vries um which are um a little bit
different in that
um they they sort of directly work uh on
on the V trees that we have in in sort
of the general circuit representation
but uh you can still see that that they
have a very uh very similar structure in
terms of what makes this v3q
constrainted so the point here is that
uh q1 Q2 and Q3 are kind of uh before
the other variable y in the in the in in
the um in the v Tree in some sense uh
and so if you have a STD a sentential
decision diagram which or probabilistic
version of a sentential decision diagram
which satisfies this Q constraint vree
then again you can do marginal map or
the the sorts of things we discussed um
so basically we have you know a we have
a whole bunch of queries uh which we'll
see are sort of closely related um and
then we have a whole bunch of sort of
formalisms for how to describe you know
when or or how you can do uh uh you know
do these inferences um so what I'd like
to do in this talk essentially is to uh
try to come up with um you know a
circuit view of um of what it means to
uh to be able to do these to be able to
answer these queries queries trably uh
because all of these uh and all search
grass fact by databases arithmetic
circuits SDS they're essentially
circuits so we want some sort of um sort
of circuit property type type
um uh type framework where um we can say
yes this is the condition that we need
specifically for tractability rather
than necessarily worrying too much about
uh precisely where the uh where the
circuit came from
um okay so just an outline or sort of a
a summary of uh what have been trying
trying to motivate here so we want sort
of a unifying language for describing
these kinds of circuits which can
compute marginal map and the other
queries uh tractably
um and the reason that is is then of
course we can uh look at any domain
where we have these sorts of problems
and then just turn them into a circuit
and then we can just analyze the circuit
using this using this sort of language
uh as as always in in knowledge
compilation right um another advantage
of um of doing this is that um by sort
of turning it into into purely purely
circuit language um then
um you know it certain things become
more obvious or maybe not obvious is the
right word but but but easier to derive
uh than if you looked at problem
specific Frameworks so you we can maybe
get some better understanding or of uh
what is the sort of what is really
underlying all of these uh algorithms
which all essentially rely on circuits
um
and finally um I'm also going to talk a
little bit about compositionality so uh
once we have this sort of language for
circuits then uh we can go ahead and uh
not just look at marginal map or the
necessarily the queries I just I just
showed you but uh look at sort of what
is you know how far can we extend uh the
range of queries which which we can
answer
um okay
so I'm now going to go into the sort of
um uh technical portion of the of the
talk um hopefully uh we generally know
what a what a probabilistic circul is uh
now but I'll still go over the go go
over it just to just to be sure we're
all on the same page um so uh Proby
circle is basically a rooted graph where
uh each node represents uh a distrib
ution over set of variables which we
call it scope and denote like like so um
and then essentially we have uh three
types of nodes we have um Leaf nodes
which usually correspond to simple base
distributions so maybe a A univariant
gussian or or a discrete uh discrete
distribution um and then we have product
noes which essentially um uh make make
an independent assumption so you have
have have the the product of the two
distributions uh and then we have these
um these Su noes which are essentially
mixtures of uh mixtures of the
components um okay and here's an example
of a of a probabilistic circuit over
three binary variables um so here are
some some of the Key properties that we
want so uh decomposability uh says that
the children of a product node have uh
disjoint Scopes so uh it should be
pretty easy to see here that these uh
that the circular is decomposable if you
look at any product node then the set of
variables which appear on one side are
disjoint from the set of variables which
appear on the other side um we also have
smoothness which is saying that the
children of a sum node have the same
scope um so again you can look at the Su
and see that um you know um the children
of the SN mention the same set of
um and finally we have determinism which
is usually phrased as saying that um the
children of a sum node correspond to
different values of of of the scope of
the of the node so
um you know essentially if you look on
the on the left hand side of the root
sum node uh all of the XYZ values which
are possible on the left side are not
possible on the right side and and vice
versa
another way of of saying this is to say
that the essentially the support of the
children are are
disjoint um and yeah another way of
saying it if you want to look at it from
a logical perspective or if you're
looking at a logic circuit is uh you
know convert this essentially into into
a logic circuit uh you know replace the
the the sums with um with ores and uh
products with ANS and remove the weights
and then you're basically saying that
the that the conjunction of of of the of
the two child children uh form is is
unsatisfiable um okay hopefully this is
clear um so we've also seen structur
decomposability
so structur decomposability is basically
uh Stronger version of decomposability
which says that circuit um
um circuit decomposes its scope in a in
a particular way so um
basically we're going to say that uh a
circuit structured decomposable if it
respects some V tree um and what does it
mean to respect some V Tre uh well it
means that the scope of the product NOS
decomposed according to the V tree so if
we see for example the the product node
just below the root sum node then you
can see this decomposes the the um the
variables into x and z and then Y and so
this corresponds to node one in the
uh in the v tree yeah um and you can
also see that the product nodes which
split into x and z will correspond to
NO2 and the V2 um so it basically just
means throughout the circuit the the de
decomposition of variables happens in
the same way um so yeah this circuit um
is structur decomposable smooth and
deterministic as I as
exp okay so now let's look at map
inference uh before we look at marginal
map so map is basically uh this
operation where you uh maximize the
probability over all possible values of
of of the
variables um and okay so how do we do
that for this circuit well uh we know
that if the circuit is deterministic
then we can do this attractively in in
in linear time um and how do we do this
uh basically you can just replace the
the leaf nodes with ones and replace the
sums with maximizations and then do do a
a bottomup computation here so you can
see here that we have the most uh uh the
most likely State having 0.504
probability uh and if you sort of uh
follow the trace of of what's going on
here you can also get the actual values
of X Y and Z which achieve
this um so basically if we have
determinism we can do map inference uh
what about marginal map so marginal map
the difference is that we're
marginalizing out set of
variables um and then we're doing this
maximization um so one sort of simple
thing you can do is just uh write this
literally as a as a composition of two
two operations or a composition of two
uh of two things that you're doing so
this marginalization is literally saying
we take our circuit and we somehow
discard the variables H and then we go
ahead and do this do do this
maximization which we just showed how
how we can do
now what's the problem with this well
sometimes it works so here I'm showing
you if Q is uh x and z and H is uh y um
then yeah all we've done is marginalized
out y we've gotten rid of that component
um and now if you look at this um this
is still a a deterministic circuit
deterministic and decomposable circuit
so uh so actually we're done here we we
basically said okay we can marginalize
and then we have a deterministic circuit
so we can compute the compute the map
which means we can do the marginal map
uh with respect to Q um but this doesn't
always work right so um if instead Q was
the sets X and Y then this is what you
would get from from doing the
marginalization um and what you see that
is that that this is no longer
deterministic um so if you look
carefully then um for the root sum node
you see that both children of this of
this root sum node can cover all values
of X and Y right um and as soon as this
happens this means that we can uh we can
no longer do do do uh do map inflence
tra um and
so essentially we've run into a bit of a
roadblock um
okay so how do we sort of describe this
condition right what is it about the
circuit uh which um makes it so that uh
we can uh we can do marginal determinism
so we can do marginal map with respect
to to this CU but not that other CU um
so this uh this uh nice definition by um
by Yu Jong Antonio and others um uh
called marginal determinism um and so
I'll sort of give you the formal
definition um
but uh you know don't worry too much
about all the details I'll give an
example straight afterwards so a su node
is Q
deterministic um if where where Q is a
set of variables if this
subq um for the children of that sum
node are disjoint uh is this sub Q uh
the subq is basically the set of values
uh of Q uh for which that that uh um
that uh node has a has a positive value
or positive
probability um so another way you can
see this is um you can also just write
this as a as a logical formula you can
also say uh you know convert it into
logical Circuit look at The Logical form
Delta n Delta NJ uh and then essentially
uh you know do this existential
quantification over over the other
variables um and then we say that a
circuit is Q
deterministic um uh if for every sum
node um either this sum node doesn't
mention the Q variables at all or it has
to be Q
deterministic um so you know there's a
lot here um but essentially this is
precisely specifying what we need for
for this procedure that that I just
described to work um okay
um so here's an example um so this
circuit is XYZ
deterministic um why is that well we we
sort of saw that uh it's deterministic
right so for every value of x uh y and z
um when you go go to a uh when you go to
a sum node then we have have different
values of this this XYZ uh uh Tuple um
and so this actually this XYZ
determinism is exactly saying
determinism our normal
determinism um we can also do this
exercise for XZ determinism um so
basically you check for all of the sum
nodes um that uh they correspond that
the children correspond to different
values of x and z uh and if you squint a
little at the at the Summers you'll see
that this is this is true um and note
the condition before where I said that
um either the scope doesn't overlap or
it's Q deterministic so that's basically
to cover the case where um so you have
these these sum nodes which contain the
variable y um and so we basically want
to say we we don't we don't need this
this property for for that some node um
because we we'll get rid of the the Y
anyway um so this this is just precisely
saying saying the the condition we need
uh to do the to do the procedure I
described
before
um however it's not XY deterministic um
why is it not XY
deterministic um well this is because um
as you can can sort of see here um the
children of the root sum node can have
uh
can have overlapping values of X and Y
right and this be became very obvious
when we marginalized out the the Z from
the from the from the
circuit
um okay so so
basically um if a circuit is Q
deterministic then we can do marginal
map for for for that Q um so in this
case we can do it for Q XYZ so that's
just map because this is determinism um
and we can also do it for Q course XC um
yes
we in the coresponding so the template
of this one do you have to go over the
instance of the so it's not um it's not
visible or specified just in the v tree
um there are specific cases where you
give additional semantics to the uh to
the V3 where where it does show up but
um but no generally no
any other questions uh if there's
anything which is unclear yeah yeah so
what's the benefit of Def defining like
this instead just saying after you
remove variable it remains different
different um well it it's really it's
really the same thing this is just a um
I guess sort of um a precise definition
but if you look closely at at what what
it's saying it's exactly the same as
saying you you you marginalize out the
variable because marginalizing out the
variable uh is saying that um uh you
know if the if the scope of the sum node
doesn't doesn't overlap uh then this
basically means that we can just
completely remove that node uh when
we're when when we're marginalizing
right so when so you know and um
basically if you if you marginalize then
what you're doing is is essentially uh
sort of moving to this to this uh uh to
this support um and so this this then
um
um because if you sort of marginalize
all the other variables or essentially
existentially quantify the the other
variables um then you end up with with
this with this subq um and yeah it's
precisely the condition to say you
marize out the other variables and the
circuit is then deter
istic questions
yeah yes yeah um
so uh so yes it will
um uh yeah you can do it preserving
decomposability
okay um any other questions just so
we're all on the same
page
okay
um okay so now um sort of I guess one
thing to notice is that marginal
determinism is not one property right
it's not like determinism uh in the
sense that we can Define marginal
determinism for any subset Q of the
variables that's why we say Q
determinism um so this is like a family
of of properties defined for for each
subset of variables Q okay um and so we
would like some more uh systematic way
of understanding
um understanding uh what marginal
determinisms are possible or how these
properties all interact right because
um actually it turns out that there is
no real simple relationship between
different Q determinism properties so
for example it's not the case that if Q
is deterministic then um every superet
of it sorry if if it's if a circle is Q
deterministic then then it's Q
deterministic for superet or subset or
anything like this that that doesn't
necessarily hold um
so what for what qes a a circuit uh
satisfies Q determinism um you know it's
very it's very
unclear um so for example as I said you
might be interested in saying for for
given circuit what Q's um is is that
circuit Q deterministic uh and so and
therefore can I
um how of use it to uh do do do
inference and uh to do to do modal map
inference for example and also sort of
how do I think about these Q
deterministic circuits in terms of Vries
for example um so what we're what I'm
going toce here is these mdv trees which
are a template for marginal determinism
in structure decomposable C so
um you'll see what I mean by a template
very shortly but this is just the
definition syntactically of what an MDB
tree is it's basically a v tree where
each node is annotated with this label s
of M um and this label is essentially
either a subset of variables or it's uh
equal to U where uh U is the universal
set that means it's it's a superet of of
all other sets um
so I I'll sort of show you intuitively
what it means what this means um so the
semantics are basically like this so
we're going to say that a circuit
respects an mdv tree if it respects the
V tree so essentially it's structure
decomposable um and also that every sum
node is uh Sim deterministic where s is
the corresponding Retreat node so let's
have a look at this example um so you've
seen what I've added to these um to
these V3 nodes is this set right is a
set for each node um and this is
precisely the the MDB tree label uh okay
and
then um what does it mean for a circuit
to respect this MDB tree well if we look
at the top sum node um that's going to
correspond to um the the the uh the top
B Tre node uh one uh and then what we're
saying is that that node has to be XZ
deterministic um which means that the
children correspond to different values
of XC and you can do this with the other
sum nodes as well for example for the
for the um you know for the leftmost Su
node you can correspond that to to the
V3 node too um and then um
again you're saying that this sudee has
to be XZ deterministic which which it is
okay so um the way to think of this mdv
tree is it's a template or a
specification for a class of circuits or
a set of
circuits um such that certain nice
things are true about the class of c um
and those certain nice things will be
tractability essentially um but yes this
is this is a temp um does this sort of
make sense
um okay um so I'm not going to go into
too much of the details in the interest
of time but uh I will touch on a few
interesting facts about MDB trees um and
this is I guess my promise about um
there being some interesting things you
might be able to see by by working in
this sort of like purely uh circuit
based framework right we're just talking
in terms of V trees and and properties
of nodes um which may not have been
obvious in some of the previous um some
of the other Frameworks so um one
interesting thing is that um okay so so
firstly the kind of point of defining
this mdv tree is that it actually gives
us a set of sets Q for which we can
guarantee that the circuit is q
determinist
so as in we can read this MDB tree and
that guarantees us that uh the any
circuit respecting this MDB tree will
have certain Q
determinisms okay so so that's what I
mean by by it's a template um
furthermore what we can actually do is
uh it turns out you can you can
enumerate this efficiently for
for so here's the example um basically
when we were going from from the V tree
here uh we go to here where now what I'm
showing is um essentially a set of a set
of sets yeah a set of marginal
determinisms and at the top we have
essentially at the root we have these
two sets of marginal determinisms and
this is precisely what we solve through
our like case analysis previously where
we saw that this that the the circuit
would be XZ and X zy deterministic but
actually just through the mdv tree we
can efficiently you know there's an
efficient algorithm to essentially
comput this um and this is um this this
is great because basically we can just
work on the level of the MDB tree when
considering uh what what tracability we
have
um okay
so again this is something which um
hopefully is not completely obvious um
let's move on to the second part so now
I've said that given uh given an mdv
tree I can determine the set of uh
marginal determinisms which it
guarantees uh can we do something
slightly different so given a v tree so
this is just a variable decomposition
and any sets set of marginal
determinisms so this is any subset of
the power set of the set of variables
okay um so you know s would be uh this
XC and XC y sub set um it TS out that's
a very simple algorithm for any V tree
uh to be able to enforce this um and
this is kind of surprising because a lot
of the times with uh with with
especially with uh Vries and in terms of
how how we think about about this we
often assume that there has to be some
sort of variable
decomposition uh which then enables your
your your marginal map but it turns out
that this is not the case uh really the
important thing is this sort of support
decomposition right and this kind of
gives you the the the sort of like uh
direct sort of justification for that um
so here basically we took our V tree and
then we said okay we want this uh this
this uh we want an MDB tree for this V
tree which is uh q deterministic and if
you follow this algorithm you
essentially get get get get this and you
can do this for any any V Tre so any
variable
decomposition um so the kind of Point
here is that sort of scope and support
decomposition are in some sense at least
you can do them
authorin um the catch is that this is
not always a good idea because the
expressivity of the circuit may depend
on the interactions between the V tree
and and the marginal determin but at
least in principle you can do it um this
is one of the sort of things which is
kind of I guess not so clear when you
look at things like f trees and and and
uh and pseudo trees and so on where you
know the sort of support decomposition
you do by conditioning on on a variable
is very much tied to the sort of um to
the scope decomposition as well in some
sense um and okay a third interesting
fact is actually you know there are
loads of different mdv trees right like
we can label our mdv tree with what
other sets we want but actually only a
few of them make sense um which of them
make sense well we're going to say which
ones don't make sense so an mdv tree is
inadmissible
if there exists another mdv tree which
is at least as tractable with respect to
Marginal determinism that means it
implies all marginal determinisms which
which which W implies uh so yeah
intuitively we have another MDB tree
which is which is at least
distractable um but also um this new V
Tre is strictly more general which means
that there exists a circuit which is
captured by by by this W Prime which is
not captured by W and also of course all
all circuits captured by W captured by
W um so this is basically saying well
you know if we want sort of intuitively
we want sort of uh the most
General um you know the most General
class of circuits where we have a
certain tractability condition then um
we can um uh then we don't want these
inadmissible MDB trees uh and one
interesting thing we found found is that
um essentially uh psdd or more
accurately strong determinism uh is is
actually not admissible as in you can do
uh you can do something you can do
something better um okay um so yeah B
basically the the summary of this is um
Andes are circuit templates so they're
designed in such a way that we just
we're just interested in what uh sort of
tractability guarantees we can get from
for from from from this template um you
can have your favorite method for for
generating circuses an mdv tree and then
uh if we can if we can sort of Express
this as an MDB tree then uh we can do
the things which I sort of described in
the interesting facts um and another
difference which might be a little bit
instructive is that unlike some of these
other trees we don't really care about
how the support is decomposed we just
care that it is decomposed in some so it
doesn't we don't have to sort of
condition on all values of two variables
for example we can do this
split into two components and it has has
no implication on tracability because I
think I'm running out of time um I will
sort of try
to I guess probably roughly I have no
time left right spend a few
minutes um okay so I'm going to show the
application of this to to causal
influence which I promised at the start
um
so essentially in causal inference or at
least level two on the on the pole
hierarchy you're interested in uh sort
of quantities of this form P of Y given
given do a uh and this intuitively is
the causal effect of of a on y um in
general this is not equal to the
conditional and this is just saying
correlation is not
causation um and sort of what you can do
is you you can sort of specify some uh
assumptions on your system in the form
of a causal diagram so so these are two
examples and then given that causal
diagram you can actually write this P of
Y given do a as a purely probabilistic
expression okay but this expression will
differ depending on the
graph um so okay so if we have the graph
then we have a purely probabilistic
expression so then we want to know when
can we compute this this probabilistic
uh expression and it turns out that this
is essentially hard for for structure
decomposable smooth and deterministic
circuits so this is where you know
marginal determinism comes in um but how
do we sort of approach a problem like
this right how do we approach a problem
like this summation over over products
with conditionals well one way of of
doing this and this is uh a very nice
paper which I which I recommend you uh
all to read by by Antonio uh G yujong
and others uh is to express this query
as a as a composition of basic
operations so in this case these basic
operations are
marginals products and conditionals um
you know if you squinted this for a
while you can see that this is basically
saying what's what's in
the um and okay so once you have this
essentially you want to analyze how each
of these basic operations affects your
mdv
tree and then one and then by pushing
this mdv tree forward through this
composition you can then check whether
it satisfies the the conditions you need
uh for the for the query to be tractable
um that's the sort of high level
overview um you know what do we mean by
basic operations well here's a bunch and
here's a bunch of sort of results on
these basic operations uh but suffice to
say um yeah for example for for database
folks um modalization is like uh
projection instantiation like um
selection I think and then products
select joins um so these are just
operations um and okay so you can sort
of use the mdv trees and do a bit more
work uh and combine it with this
compositional uh inference framework and
you can figure out that actually uh you
know if you have a structure
decomposable and a a a union z
deterministic uh circuit uh then there
is a quadratic algorithm for for the and
of course the formula differs for
different graphs but for these other
graphs we can also
derive which we didn't know how to do
before okay so that's for quickly some
some open questions um you know do we
have some good characterization of
marginal determinism for non-structured
circuits or marginal map for
non-structured circuits um this I don't
really know um any cases you know I'd be
very interested if anyone knows of any
cases where where marginal map is not it
is tractable through reasons other than
sort of marginal determinism so
basically anything which wasn't what I
described on the on on with the four uh
you know the four trees
um and um also
um yeah so so when I describ the
difference between STDs and that these
circuits and being tractable for the
same thing uh essentially uh if we
actually want a separation we need to
sort of show a separation between
structured and deterministic circuits
and structured and strongly
deterministic circuits
far as I know uh there is no such result
so okay great uh thank you and sorry for
running over
[Applause]
time so we have time for one question I
guess well the next
speaker ask it or
not bit on this marginal determinism for
non-structured circuits ideally if you
have a way to represent your
hierarchical scope the composition
that's a region graph when you can split
every scope into multiple ways different
partitions you can still annotate that
so right yes yeah uh that's a good point
so if you have a sort of small number of
components of
struct I'm saying the circuit is not
structur composable it's just
decomposable and you have the region
graph and you still
[Music]
annotate right the Union right uh yes
yes I think that that's that's possible
yeah yeah that' be quite interesting
because yeah we don't have to be tied to
[Music]
um thank you for the nice talk maybe I
missed it but I was wondering if I give
you two dnf that are structured along
the same md3 mdv Tre could you do the
apply and still be structur along this
mtv3 um yes you can do apply operations
even for just just same R right right so
then and you you you keep this uh this
determinism
right yes so actually it turns out and
this is shown in in the uh paper I
referenced by Anton and and and others
that um actually you yeah for sort of C
probabilistic circuit you don't need
determinism even you just need
structuredness to to to do problems yeah
yeah but my point was admit that you
want to do marginalized map and you know
the variables you want to marginalize
on uh and you want to compile your
problem into something that has this Q
determinism yes if you if you
can uh do some bottom up compilation
where you ensure this Q determination
then this is this is good right you yes
so my question was yeah can can you do
that manner in limited cases so
essentially I think what you're saying
is work backwards right you want some
end product to be Q deterministic for
example or deterministic and you want to
work backwards to figure out what you
need symbolically in terms of the mdv
trees to get there um
so in general I think this will probably
need some sort of computational effort
to do I have some sort of sufficient
conditions you can apply and see if they
work essentially uh so working back and
and sort of figuring out uh uh you know
if these conditions hold then we can do
this but it's certainly not complete
like there you uh the actual analysis
requires probably more case an question
is a little simpler in the sense that if
I have two uh circuits that perect the
same mdv Tre and I join them or multiply
them will it persp the same mdp again or
will you lose or add
some thanks
okay thank you um
so I think it will respect the same same
MDB but but but I have to you could and
then you get for automatically compiler
that can enforce some
termin thank you good I think we
uh over time so thanks Benji again thank
you